well that doesn't look good
hello Lucy Liu I'm a North Carolina it's
the start of what is going to be five
long weeks of business travel and
business meetings I'm trying to get
better at business meetings also while
I'm here I'm setting for myself the goal
of escaping from America not fatter than
I arrived because I've fallen off the
health bandwagon a bit lately and I
really don't want to make things worse
but that might be impossible given that
in America the streets are paved with
doughnuts but I'm gonna try
and right now that's future Gray's
problem current gray is on the porch
with the dog visiting family so no more
vlogging and let's skip to Denver
Colorado just stopping off to get some
coffee and use the restroom and tornado
shelter and eat bad food strangely
for details later on to San Jose
California just south of San Francisco
work travel is never fun but it's extra
not fun when you've arrived at the hotel
to find out that they don't have your
room that you booked months ago
the reservation they have but not the
room suspiciously it seems many people
who booked the hotel rooms at a super
cheap ranks before the hotels realize
that WWDC had changed locations to a new
city those people don't have rooms the
rooms have been re-rented at a higher
price so what happens to the people who
do have a reservation
why conveniently they put you in a hotel
on the other side of the city a hotel
with the douchiest privacy please sign
I've ever seen but I didn't fly across
an ocean and a continent to be 45
minutes away from all of the reasons
that I'm here so I was rather firm with
the hotel and suddenly like magic they
did have a free upgrade to a better room
but not for tonight so I still have to
be at this place and I can't set up any
of my work and it won't be until I drive
back tomorrow morning that I can
actually get started even here in
fairness the apology suite is quite nice
and it comes with an apology letter and
apology chocolates that I can't eat
because I must escape from America not
fatter travel protip you can have stuff
delivered to the hotel so you don't have
to pack it
[Music]
this is only half the boxes I have to
unpack and I didn't unpack all the boxes
in the boxes but as I switched hotels
this morning I'm running out of time
before WWDC begins so I need to get out
of here WDC is a conference where apple
brings developers from the wide world to
announce new features of their software
so programmers can implement them a
ticket inside is a front road to the
future I don't have a ticket I've got a
hotel room and a wish list which is far
more funny for crowd reactions anyway
and fooling around on Twitter during the
boring parts Wow II know it's over now
it's time to set up my mobile office
watch some technical talks customizing
your cheeseburger is way easier when
someone steps you through the process
attend tech podcast to discuss the tech
sometimes with sing-alongs
which brings us to why am I here at the
end of WWDC it's to record a podcast
about WWDC the podcast is called cortex
on a network called relay and that's
another reason that I'm here is there's
a big real a listener meetup that I'm
going to pass gray didn't film anything
at the event but to be fair to him he
was running on low power mode at that
point I really find jet lag so
frustrating on this trip
I'm trying to acclimatize to West Coast
time I was out last night at the relay
podcast
Meetup I was just talking to people and
then POW I was hit with that I'm going
to fall asleep immediately feeling so I
come back to the hotel to get a good
night's sleep but no of course Here I am
it's 4:00 in the morning I know I'm just
gonna be awake for a while like zombie
thanks jet lag
I was on my way to go find some coffee I
think this is uh this is what I need to
do today
this is goal number one but later coffee
first
all right time to do this I tried to do
some fancy camera work but then this
happened so forget that no more
recording in gyms while I'm doing weight
stuff but feels super weird to vlog then
anyway
America is a place where you can really
double down on your eating mistakes
I really want to avoid that so my plan
while I'm here is just to cut out as
many carbohydrates as I can from my diet
this means no pancakes no bread no
pastas no pizza no crackers normally the
kind of stuff that I would eat an
enormous amount of when I'm under a lot
of pressure and doing a lot of work then
since I'm also traveling at the same
time it's kind of doubly hard but it is
possible to do if you can eat the eggs
but not the muffin so I'm going to the
supermarket to load up on all the kinds
of things that I'm gonna be eating lots
of meat and cheese and eggs and
emergency almonds and emergency jerky
it's not fun and it's not what I want to
do but this is the most simple and
effective thing that I have found in the
past for dropping or maintaining weight
and if there's one thing I could use
this summer it's a bit of simple thank
you check out robots conferencing is
mentally taxing but I find it helps to
map the outlines of the day and try to
specify what objectives for time
well-spent are what I need to do who I
need to see what sessions I should go to
and is a personal development point I'm
trying to get better at meeting with
interesting people while in business
traveling and these conferences can be a
crazy overlapping puzzle of everyone's
schedules right now I'm on my way to a
meeting with someone the only time we
could find for both of us that
overlapped is while he's packing his
bags to go that's where I'm headed
all right packing meeting over onto more
stuff
the no carbohydrates health plan is
going pretty well so far but now during
business meetings I'm the weirdo who's
not eating the burger bun and has to
explain why I recognized the model of
truck
have you not I've been lucky enough to
be invited out to see some interesting
headquarters in the past including
Dropbox and Facebook
this time it's Google with there why is
there a dinosaur over there and this is
a sad just hope in graveyard Android
past and office interior they really
rather you didn't film then on to the
computer history museum with so many
buttons I want to press them all and
remembered fun things long-forgotten
and dramatic things long-forgotten
[Music]
and got totally distracted by seeing my
first Tesla charger in real life Oh God
Tesla's Tesla's as far as the eye can
see oh this is the ex
I'm pretty tired and I really don't want
to been a long day but I'm going into
the gym and everywhere you go in America
screams screams screams but you know
what thank you but no thank you
all right I'm doing this pretty pleased
about that
I had just they really didn't want to do
it but I'd only just barely started a
streak of exercising so I wasn't gonna
quit on the third day but yeah not a
thing that I wanted to do but I'm very
glad it's done and now it's shower time
[Music]
have yet to be at a conference that
doesn't feel like it's just one day too
long and this is the last day the big
responsibility today is to record cortex
but before that happens I want to try to
fit in just a little bit of exercise I'm
gonna get my bicycling in while I
prepare for cortex
so I've got the bike it looks like on
the map is a park along the Guadalupe
River so I'm taking the bike there I'm
gonna go for a little bit of a ride and
I've gotten into the habit oh there we
go quite a leap a river park I've gotten
into the habit of not listening to music
while I do aerobic exercise
it makes exercising a good time to think
and like today I'm going to be combining
the exercise with preparing for cortex
so I've taken a look at the show notes
I've loaded them up in my head I'm gonna
go for a little bike ride and think
about what I'm gonna talk about on
cortex today just as soon as I can
figure out how to get down into the park
now it's time to attach the GoPro
perfect
feels like terminator
[Music]
thanks little buddy that's way better
than cycling indoors time for shower and
podcast oh no this is the worst I have
to hide now for a little while I'm gonna
be late to the podcast
can't do a podcast unless you have
enough coffee to get through a podcast
I'm bringing the coffee I finally did it
would you do we're in the same place
we're working on something together in
the same place or at WWC again we are
but last year you made me record in a
hotel room and you were in your hotel
room and we use Skype yes that's true
this year
mm-hmm you suggested why don't we record
a person I didn't suggest it I feel like
you did you suggested it okay and I
agreed because I have a lot of audio
equipment in my room right now that I
really didn't want to go in box ah that
makes sense
okay for the bun no me
everyone is gone I'm still here because
I need an extra day to prepare there's a
place I need to get to you by a certain
time and it's a bit it's going to end up
being a bit involved so I'm guessing
this vlog which I originally thought was
just going to be a short thing at some
conferences is going to end up being a
much longer thing like two or three
parts I don't know that's future Grey's
editing problem now Grey's problem is
packing four suitcases and stuff the
rule is only bags go inside of suitcases
not things bags in suitcases things can
go into bags not in the suitcase all
right I got the packing done way faster
than expected because of course I
realized I don't need to pack it well I
just need to get it all boxed up so I
right now
to this point anyway with 19 home runs
sure it looked up the way on the camera
but holy hell
[Music]
bloom here the day before VidCon starts
the pre-conference feeling is nice I
always like being in places before the
action happens as it's being set up it's
the feeling of potential all that
potential of what could be before what
actually happens empties you to the core
and this conference this VidCon is
particularly draining because the longer
you spend time near LA the more
desaturation your life becomes la is a
Dementor in city form but right now I'm
still fresh I like exploring I like the
feeling of solitude in places that
should be full it's peaceful and it
won't stay that way for long
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
stay close coffee I need you now more
than ever
I'm so exhausted and these cookies are
everywhere depleting my willpower and
all of the lounges everywhere there
aren't crowds there are cookies cookie
would feel so good right now but I must
resist in case you're wondering I stayed
off of carbs during part two it's been
about three weeks so far without carbs
and this is the final hard stretch as
VidCon is such an assault on the mind
and to cope with it I've chosen poorly
in years past but Brady's gonna want to
see a snap from you okay I'm making
better choices this time but America
really doesn't help when there's a pizza
button on the phone and a sign for the
pizza button I think they really want me
to eat pizza but I'm going to stay
strong only two weeks left to escape
from America not fatter
[Music]
I feel like this place is the opposite
of me
[Applause]
so much screaming and filming
[Music]
so the question was you guys with your
cameras everywhere behind you can't see
me
amazing
there's people everywhere well almost
everywhere really killed was the mass
media business model we try to take that
scare should you be swallowing this
abundant speech world prices go down
desperation goes up we end up with cats
with cats and Kardashians see is the
ultimate looking and it worked right so
how do we we think the business model of
news and good luck with that
future gray taking over here as at this
point past gray was really pushed beyond
his social limits suddenly there is no
more talking to the camera there's just
simply no more talking
this first summer of grey was exhausting
beyond my ability to explain but it was
also a great and hugely successful trip
I wanted to try to have more meetings
with people and boy did I ever but it
was time to go I needed a break and
there was a place that I wanted to go
where I could just be quiet and not have
to see people and not have to do
anything and just recharge for a while
so that's where I went and there is
perhaps nothing more uplifting to the
human soul than taking a flight out of
LA to a place where you actually want to
be so I recharged for a while I went
back to North Carolina to see my family
again and then I returned home to London
and thus ended the summer of grey
all right I also came back not fatter
I can easily do this by having a
performance due tomorrow